قصف اسرائيلي يستهدف مطار حلب الدولي
باربعه صواريخ وسماع دوي انفجارات شمال
غرب سوريا
واشنطن لا ترى اي مؤشرات تفيد بانتهاء
الحرب في اوكرانيا قريبا والبنتاجون يسرع
بتسليم دبابات الى اوكرانيا
[تصفيق]
باريس تشتعل بالاحتجاجات اشتباكات الليليه
عنيفه بين الشرطه والمحتاجين على قانون
التقاعد
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
افاد مراسل العربيه بسماع يدوي
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا واللاذقيه وحلب
واوضح مراسل العربيه نقلا عن مصادر محليه
بان القصف الاسرائيلي استهدف ايضا مطار
حلب الدولي باربعه صواريخ مادى الى توقف
حركه الملاحه وكان مطار حلب قد تعرض لقصف
مماثل في السابع من الشهر الجاري ادى الى
وقوع اضرار ماديه وخروجه عن الخدمه
قال البيت الابيض نصين اذا رغبت بي لاعبي
دور بناء في اوكرانيا فعليها الضغط على
روسيا لوقف الحرب وقد وصفت اوصف المتحدث
باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي في البيت
الابيض جون كاربي وصف موقف الصين من الحرب
باوكرانيا بالطرف غير المحايد واضاف البيت
الابيض انه لم يرى اي شيء مما قاله الرئيس
بوتين والرئيس الصيني يدفع
واشنطن للاعتقاد بان حرب اوكرانيا ستنتهي
كما قال جون كاربي ان واشنطن لا تريد وقفا
للنار في اوكرانيا الان لان ذلك سيجمد
المعارك وسيعطي بوتين الوقت والمكان
لاعاده تجهيز قوته
لا نريد ان نرى وقف اطلاق النار في الوقت
الحالي لان وقف اطلاق النار وتجميد الخطوط
في مكانها يمنح بوتين بشكل اساسي الوقت
والمساحه التي يحتاجها لمحاوله اعاده
التجهيز واعاده التدوير والتعويض عن انفاق
الموارد
وكانت روسيا والصين قد اصدرت بيانا مشتركا
عقب مباحثات
ان او قالت فيه ان العلاقات بينهما وصلت
على اعلى مستوى لها على الاطلاق لكنها
ليست موجهه ضد اي دوله اخرى وقد اتهمت
موسكو وبكين الولايات المتحده بتقويض
الامن العالمي وشدد الجانبان على ضروره
الحيلوله دون اندلاع حرب نوويه لانه لن
يكون فيها رابح
ورحب طرفان بتطبيع العلاقات بين السعوديه
وايران واعرب عن دعمهما لحمايه السلام
والاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط
اعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
الجنرال ان واشنطن قررت نقلا نسخه قديمه
من دبابات ابرامز الى اوكرانيا من اجل
تسريع عمليه تسليم في غضون ثمانيه الى
عشره اشهر
قررت وزاره الدفاع بالتنسيق مع اوكرانيا
تزويدها بدبابات ابرامز من طراز ام واحد
اي واحد ما سيسمح بتسريع وقت التسليم بشكل
كبير الى خريف هذا العام هذه الدبابات
تتمتع بقدره قتاليه مشابهه جدا لطراز ام
واحد اي اثنين
تستعد روسيا واوكرانيا لمرحله جديده من
الصراع مع حلول فصل الربيع استعدادات من
الجانبين تهدد جهود السلام بالفشل خاصه
المساعي الصينيه والورقه التي اعدتها لوقف
القتال
[موسيقى]
اصوات البنادق والمدافع في اوكرانيا لا
تترك اي مجال لسماع نداءات الحلحله
السلميه من ربيع العام الماضي الى ربيع
العام الحالي مده زمنيه استعرت فيها نيران
الحرب اكثر فاكثر المرحله المقبله تحمل
نذر قتال ضار صحيفه
تستعد لمعركه الربيع في وقت حذر رئيس
مجموعه فاجنر من ان الجيش الاوكراني يخطط
لهجوم الوشيك يهدف الى فصل قواته عن الحشد
الرئيسي للجيش الروسي الصحيفه ذاتها اكدت
ان اوكرانيا تستعد لدفع الروس بعيدا عن
مناطق سجلوا فيها انتصارات محدوده خلال
الشتاء مثل بخموت مدينه الواقعه على مشارف
دونيتسك في مرمى نيران للقوات الروسيه
التي تسعى لبدء هجومها الربيعي هجوم تقول
كيف انه على وشك التلاشي غير ان استخدام
روسيا لصواريخها الاسرع من الصوت اذا
استمر فان اوكرانيا قد يستطيع الحفاظ على
التوازن الدقيق في تزويد الطاقه والخدمات
الاخرى ما يصعب عليها الامور اكثر فاكثر
المعاناه في الحرب لا تقتصر على طرف دون
الاخر القوه الروسيه هي الاخرى تتكبد
خسائر فادحه لانها تهاجم مستخدمه طرقا
معروفه للجيش الاوكراني
تطورات على الارض تسير عكس الجهود
المبذوله خاصه تلك التي تقوم بها الصين
دول غربيه طالبت
على بوتين للتراجع مقابل رفض واضح من
البيت الابيض لمساعي الصين جهود تصطدم بما
يحدث على ارض المعركه
فبسبب الدعم المتزايد من الغرب للقوه
الاوكرانيه خاصه من الولايات المتحده
واصرار موسكو على تحقيق ما تريد على الارض
ورقه بيكين للتسويه قد تتمزق قبل ان يتم
توقيعها بين طرفي الصراع بلال الوجداني
العربيه
اندلعت اشتباكات عنيفه بين افراد الشرطه
الفرنسيه وعدد من المتظاهرين الذين تجمعوا
في ميدان الجمهوريه وسط العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس احتجاجا على اعتماد مشروع اصلاح
نظام التقاعد وقد جرت مواجهته متفرقه بين
بعض المحتاجين الذين اطلقوا الالعاب
الناريه في اتجاه افراد الامن التي بدورها
قامت باطلاق القنابل المسيله للدموع
لتفريقيهم وابرم المتظاهرون النيران في
حاويات القمامه المتراكمه في شوارع باريس
نتيجه اضراب عامل جمع القمامه احتجاجات
احتجاجا على المشروع الحكومي
وكانها ساحه حرب هذه هي حال شوارع فرنسا
هذه الايام حرائق مشتعله في شوارع كثيره
وقوات الشرطه والامن منتشره في كل مكان
تظاهرات عشوائيه تخرج في معظم المدن
الفرنسيه احتجاجا على اقرار قانون رفع سن
التقاعد الى 64 عاما
الاحتجاجات اخذت بعدا اخر بعد فشل
البرلمان في التصويت على مذكرتين لحجم ثقه
من الحكومه واعتبرت قوى المعارضه ان
الكلمه الان اصبحت للشارع وان اسقاط
الحكومه وحجب الثقه منها سيكون في الشارع
في العاصمه باريس ارهقت تنقل المحتجين في
كل شوارعها قوه الامن والشرطه التي اصبحت
تشن حملات اعتقالات عشوائيه ادانها
المسؤولون المنتخبون وعدد كبير من القضاه
محذرين من تبعاتها هذه احدى حالات
الاعتقال العشوائي التي تقوم بها الشرطه
والان يحاول المتظاهرون اقناع هؤلاء
الشرطه بان هذا الشخص ليس له علاقه بما
يحدث ومع انتقال المعركه الى الشارع لا
يبدو ان هذه الازمه ستنتهي قريبا فكل
الاطراف تحشد صفوفها لليوم الكبير في
الثالث والعشرين من هذا الشهر حيث سيكون
يوما للاضراب والتظاهر تدعو اليه النقبات
وكل الاحزاب اليساريه المعارضه فديده
العربيه باريس
[موسيقى]
بينما يواصل عمال النظافه الفرنسيين
اضرابهم عن عملهم على خلفيه اقرار قانون
اصلاح نظام التقاعد المثير للجدل يشكو
السياح من تراكمي الاف الاطنان من
النفايات في شوارع المدن الفرنسيه حيث
اثرت هذه الازمه على حركه السياحه في
باريس اشهر مدينه سياحيه في العالم
ماركو يعمل منذ سنوات كسائق الشاحنه لجمع
النفايات كان ينتظر بفارغ الصبر تقاعده
لكن القانون الجديد احبط عزيمته بعدما زاد
من انتظاره عامين على الاقل وتدفع
انهم محقون في اضربهم فالعمل حتى السن
الرابعه والستين مع هذا العمل الشاق امر
مستحيل خلال المطر والبرد ولدينا مشاكل
بالظهر والركبتين في هذا السن نكون قد
متنا اصلا هذا مهلك ما تفعله الحكومه
وامام معمل حرق النفايات لم يتوانى
متظاهرون من النقابات عن نصب خيامهم من
اجل دعم عمال النظافه المضربين هنا ضد
قانون رفع سن التقاعد
القانون لم يخضع اصلا للتصويت الحكومه
استخدمت البنت
49.3 من اجل تمرير القانون دون تصويت
البرلمان عليه وهذا يتعارض مع الديمقراطيه
عبر اكوام متراكمه من النفايات يحاول عمال
النظافه ايصال صوتهم الى الحكومه قد يكون
ذلك وسيلتهم الوحيده للتعبير عن غضبهم لكن
هذا المشهد المتكرر في احياء باريس بدا
يؤثر على صورتها السياحيه ويؤرق زوارها
ونزعج من المانيا
يعني انصدمت انه مليان زباله يعني مو مثل
الموعد متوقع
حتى لو في ضربات في مشاكل نظافه يعني عمال
نظافه بالذات ما في اضراب
حتى والله حاولنا نقدم لحد بس للاسف ما
لقينا ورغم جهود الحكومه في توفير شركات
خاصه لازاله النفايات من شوارع العاصمه
لكن الازمه لم تنتهي بعد وما زال فيها
اكثر من 9000 طن من القمامه وهو ما قد
يستغرق اياما عديده لجمعها
بعيدا عن اكوام النفايات المتراكمه هنا
وهناك في شارع شانزيليزي يحاول السياح
التقاط صور تذكاريه لا تشوهها الازمه
الناجمه عن قانون رفع سن التقاعد والتي
غطت على سحر اشهر مدينه سياحيه في العالم
وحولتها الى مجمع نفايات وساحه معركه
مشتعله بين الحكومه وفئات من شعبها زينه
عادي العربيه باريس
اعلن رئيس الوزراء اليوناني كرياكوس
الانتخابات العامه ستجري في مايو المقبل
لكن من دون ان يحدد موعدها بالضبط وياتي
هذا الاعلان بعد ثلاثه اسابيع من كارثه
اصطدام قطار ركاب بقطار قطار في شحن
البضائع والتي اوقعت 57 قتيلا واجعلت
احتجاجات شعبيه ضد الحكومه استقاله على
اثرها وزير المواصلات
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الامم المتحده تحذر من تفاقم شح المياه
وتنذر بخطر حدوث
ازمه عالميه
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت القوه الموقعه على
الاتفاق الايطالي عن مصفوفه زمنيه لانهاء
العمليه السياسيه وتكوين حكومه الفتره
الانتقاليه مطلع الشهر المقبل فيما قال
رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد الفتاح
البرهان خلال مخاطبته مواطنين بمنطقه ام
سياله بولايه شمال كردفان وسط السودان قال
ان البلاد مقبله على مرحله جديده وانه
سيحدث انتقال مرض للجميع سيتم توقيع
الاتفاق النهائي يوم واحد ابريل القادم ان
شاء الله
موعد جديد اعلنته القوه الموقعه على
الاتفاق لطريل لانهاء العمليه السياسيه
وتشكيل حكومه الفتره الانتقاليه وصفه
تاكيدات المكونه العسكري بالمضي قدما
لتشكيل حكومه مدنيه
المسار الهجري الان دع منه دعم كامل وباحث
راجع منه لكن بنقول والله هذا المسار اذا
ما استصحب القوه الرئيسيه اذا ما استصحب
كل السودانيين سيتعسر قريبا ولن يستطيع ان
يمضي لكن الكتله الديمقراطيه واطرافا اخرى
ما زالت ترفض الانخراط في اجتماعات هذا
المسار وترى ان ورش هذه العمليه لم تخاطب
جذور الازمه الاسره الدوليه نحن نقول بشكل
مباشر انه المنطقه غد تدخل في مواجهه
سياسيه حقيقيه اذا وصل هذا الاتفاق
الايطالي مروره على قضيه شرق السودان دون
حلها بشكل شامل لن يرى الاتفاق الايطالي
نورا في اقليم شرق السودان وهذا بمسابه
الرساله واضحه لجميع الجهات المعنيه
بالاتفاق الايطالي
فيما تزال قوه تغيير الجذري التي تضم قوى
على راسها الحزب الشيوعي وبعض لجان
المقاومه تحمل لواء الرفض التام لاي حوار
مع المكون العسكري
[موسيقى]
الاتفاق الايطالي يعتبر ان القوه الجذريه
هي معارضه لهذا الاتفاق ستكون المعارضه
المدنيه السلميه في الشوارع وفي اي مكان
كمعارضه ولم يلتفت لهم وقدم لهم دعوات
كثيره ولكن لم يقبلوا بالجلوس مع
العسكريين الخمسه هنالك ايضا الاسلاميين
يضغط على الشارع والقوى السياسيه بان
يعودوا باي شكل من الاشكال عن طريق
الاذعان او فشل المرحله الانتقاليه تسمح
لهم بالعوده مره اخرى
فيما يظل الاسلاميون يرفضون ما اسموه
بالاقصاء ويبقى التحدي الاكبر بقدره هذه
الاطراف لتنفيذ ما اتفق عليه من مواقيت
لانهاء هذه العمليه السياسيه في ظل رفض
لفاعلين في المشهد السوداني قد يعقد كثيرا
من سير هذه العمليه سالم الهاشمي العربي
الخرطوم
سجل المركز الباكستاني للارصاد الجويه هزه
ارضيه بقوه 7.7 درجات على مقياس ريختر ما
تسبب بمقتل تسعه اشخاص واصابه 44 اخرين
بحسب هيئه الطوارئ في البلاد واشارت هيئه
الارصاد الى ان مركز الهزه وقع في منطقه
هاندوكوش الجبليه شماليه البلاد والتي
تعتبر نقطه تماس بين الصفيحتين الاوراسيه
والهنديه وقد شعر بشده الهزه سكان العاصمه
اسلام اباد ومناطق واسعه من افغانستان
كبير ومديري المنتجات في جوجل جاك كراوزك
قال ان الشركه بدات الاصدار العام لروبوت
الدردشه الخاص بها بورد سعيا لجذب
المشتركين والحصول على ردود فعل على
البرنامج الذي تخوض به غمار المنافسه في
عالم الذكاء الاصطناعي مع تشات جي بي تي
المدعوم من مايكروسوفت واضاف كراوزك انه
سيتسنى للمستخدمين في الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا في بادئ الامر الانضمام الى
قائمه الانتظار للوصول الى هذا التطبيق
وفي عرض توضيحي اظهر كراوزك كيف ينشئ
نصوصا باكملها في لحظه بطريقه تختلف عن
تشات جي بي تي الذي يكتب الاجابات كلمه
بكلمه ويشتمل ايضا على
مميزه تعرض ثلاثه اصدارات مختلفه او
مسودات لاي اجابه وبها زر ابحث في جوجل
اذا رغب المستخدم في الحصول على نتائج من
على الانترنت لاي سؤال يريد معرفه اجابته
لم تتصور الحكومه الصينيه ان تمويلها
لمشروع مؤسسه الناشئه تعمل على تطوير
خوارزميات تدرس سلوك البشري سيتحول الى
عملاق عملاق تكنولوجيا يؤرق الحكومات قبل
المنافسين
من مشروع ناشئ ولد ليدرس سلوك الشعب
الصيني الى ما يصفه الغرب بالتطبيق
الشيطان الذي غزه هواتف اكثر من مليار شخص
محاربته باتت مشروعا وطنيا
البدايه كانت عام 2012 حينها كانت شركات
وادي السيليكون في امريكا تسيطر على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
وتتسابق وراء تطوير نظام الخوارزميات
الاذكى ولدت منصه الصينيه التي وصفت بوافد
متاخر لن يقدر على منافسه العمالقه
سنوات قليله وتيك توك يكسر احتكار الكبار
لا بل ينافسهم في بلدانهم السر لا يكمن في
خوارزمياته الذكيه فقط بل ايضا في توظيفها
اذ يقضي المتصفحون وقتهم في البحث عن ما
ينبي اذواقهم يعرض تيك توك حريه الخيار
مره واحده ليتكفل الذكاء الاصطناعي بدراسه
نفسيه المستخدمين واحياء رغبات يجهلونها
وهنا الخطر يقول المختصون افراز الدوبامين
او هرمون السعاده في كل مره ينال المحتوى
اعجاب المتابعين الا ان الدوبامين المفرز
يتضاعف حال الاعجاب بمحتوى مفاجئ امر لا
توفره منصه منافسه للتيك توك الحكومات
الغربيه انتقدت امتلاك الصين ملفا نفسيا
عن مواطنيها الذين يواجهون خطر الادمان
لمنتوج اسيوي هي خطوه اولى فقط يليها
الكسل والعزله وانخفاض معدلات التفكير
اما بكين فلم تجد تفسيرا لما يعيشه تيك
توك سوى انه صيني بالنسبه للخبراء تيك توك
مجرد درس عن الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي لا
ينافس البشر بل يتطور على حساب قدراتهم
حضرت الامم المتحده في تقرير من ان
الاستهلاك المفرط للمياه هو التغير
المناخي جعلان نقص المياه مستوطنا في جميع
انحاء العالم مما ادى الى خطر وشيك بحدوث
ازمه عالميه وقال تقرير للامم المتحده ان
نحو ملياري شخص يفتقرون الى مياه شرب
مامون في حين يفتقر ثلاثه مليارات و600
مليون شخص الى خدمات صرف صحيا موثوق بها
احتفلت العربيه بمرور 20 عاما على تاسيسها
في حفل في الرياض حيث اكد القائمون على
المحطه مواصله العمل للحفاظ على موقع
العربيه الرائد في فضاء الاعلام العربي
[موسيقى]
في الرياض احتفلت العربيه بعيد تاسيسها
العشرين في مارس 2003 انطلقت من مجموعه ام
بي سي وبعد ذلك التاريخ بعقدين لا تزال
رقما اساسيا في فضاء الاعلام العربي
بحضور لافت من وزراء سعوديين وعدد من
الاعلاميين والفنانين
استعرض رئيس مجلس اداره مجموعه ام بي سي
الشيخ وليد الابراهيم الهدف وراء تاسيس
العربيه وما انجزته في عشرين عاما
ولدت العربيه من غرفه اخبار ام بي سي
لتكون المتخصصه والشامله في مجالها
ومنذ البدء
كانت مشروعا وطنيا سعوديا
بعد ان ظهرت القنوات الفضائيه الاخباريه
الناطقه بالعربيه
والتي سعى بعضها
لتوجيه الراي العام
وفقا لاجندات معينه
كانت في اغلب الاحداث تتخذ مواقف سلبيه من
المملكه ومن دول الخليج
طريق نجاح العربيه لم يكن سهلا ابدا
فارواح فقدت في سبيل الوفاء بوعد المحطه
ان تعرف اكثر كما
ركز سام بارنت الرئيس التنفيذي لام بي سي
في كلمته
يجدر بي ان اسلط الضوء على 18 شخصا فقدوا
حياتهم في سبيل خدمه قناتنا في السنوات
العشرين الماضيه ويجب الا ننسى مطلقا
المخاطر التي تواجهها طواقمنا والتضحيات
التي يقدمها الكثير من الصحفيين والثمن
الذي دفعته العربيه نفتخر بهم جميعا ونحن
ملتزمون بمواصله عملهم بذات المستوى من
النزاهه على مدار العشرين عاما القادمه في
اشاره على ما يبدو في بدايه طريقها اختارت
العربيه ان يكون نهجها هو المهنيه بعيدا
عن الشعبويه والدعايه
وكانت عنصرا في معركه التنوير بعيدا عن
العنف والجهل كما يقول ممدوح المهيني
المدير العام لقناتي العربيه والحدث
العربيه لم تركن ابدا لتاريخها الطويل ففي
عيدها العشرين تعلن عن مزيد من التوسع
باطلاق اذاعه العربيه اف ام نعم انا مدير
محظوظ
لانني معكم في الرياض عاصمه المستقبل
وقبله المؤسسات العالميه الكبرى حيث تبث
العربيه نشراتها وبرامجها من استديوهاتها
وتستمر في توسعها
والياذن لمعالي وزير الاعلام وسعاده رئيس
مجلس الاداره
بالاعلان من هنا من الرياض باطلاق اذاعه
العربيه اف ام
[تصفيق]
لتكون الاقرب دوما والاقدر على استجابات
والاقدر على الاستجابه الاحتياجات الجمهور
المختلفه في احتفاليه عيد العربيه العشرين
ينظر مدير المؤسسه بعين الى ماض مشرف
وبعيين اخرى الى مستقبل تسعى خلاله
العربيه الى الحفاظ على موقعها في مقدمه
فضاء شديد التنافسيه
الى العناوين
قصف اسرائيلي يستهدف مطار حلب الدولي
باربعه صواريخ وسماع دوي في جارات شمال
غرب سوريا
لا ترى اي مؤشرات تفيد بانتهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا قريبا والبنتاجون يسرع بتسليم
دبابات الى اوكرانيا
باريس تشتعل بالاحتجاجات اشتباكات الليليه
عنيفه بين الشرطه والمحتاجين على قانون
التقاعد
اشكركم حسن متابعه مشاهدينا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]